ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en este momento
seguramente está sucediendo un delito en
tijuana
un delito que puede ser robo o asalto a
mano armada e incluso homicidio
y muy probablemente no estoy cometiendo
un joven
porque digo que muy probablemente porque
en el 90% de los delitos que suceden en
la ciudad participan jóvenes
pero no son todos los jóvenes por
supuesto son apenas el punto 7 por
ciento de los jóvenes que de alguna u
otra manera están en conflicto con la
ley en la ciudad
estos jóvenes
pueden ser
jóvenes invisibles y son invisibles para
todos nosotros hasta ese día que cometen
el delito y entonces ya volteamos a
verlos y los ponemos en el mejor de los
casos número o un n una n como apellido
y sabemos que existen que están ahí y
que tuvieron una serie de situaciones
que desconocemos pero que lo llevaron a
cometer un delito
yo tampoco los veía para mí también
fueron invisibles durante mucho tiempo
mientras estaba en este teatro varios
años o en otros lugares pero fue hasta
el 2013 cuando
pero de regreso a la ciudad de tijuana
yo soy tijuanense estuve un tiempo fuera
regreso a la ciudad de tijuana y me
encuentro con una organización civil
local que algunos de ustedes deben
conocer que se llama tijuana innovadora
y dijo a innovadora me invita a que
desarrollamos juntos un proyecto que se
llama casa de las ideas y en este lugar
que está en la colonia camino verde
donde las colonias con mayor índice
delictivo en la ciudad teníamos la
oportunidad de trabajar con población
joven población infantil donde lo que
planteamos ahí fue desarrollar un
proyecto para utilizar el arte como un
medio de transformación social trabajar
con niñas niños adolescentes y a través
del arte despertarles una nueva manera
de ver su entorno y generar un
pensamiento crítico
estos jóvenes de los que les hablaba al
principio
son jóvenes
qué dicen las autoridades cuando les
preguntan sobre la gran ola de
homicidios que ha sucedido en tijuana
dicen son esos que mencionan se están
matando entre ellos han escuchado alguna
vez esto en alguna declaración y se
están matando entre ellos
ellos son unos excluidos los externos
unos otros que no somos nosotros pero
eso básicamente se lo deben
nos lo deben a nosotros mismos ellos
pudieron potencialmente ser nosotros
ellos pudieron potencialmente
desarrollar su vida en condiciones más o
menos normales como las hemos
desarrollado todos nosotros sin embargo
están
precarizados están excluidos son jóvenes
en riesgo que se enfrentan a diferentes
situaciones les llaman ninis
y a mí me gustaría mejor llamarle
xinxing y sanín y eso también es un
concepto que muchos seguramente han
escuchado eso estos jóvenes que ni
estudian ni trabajan
yo lo cambiaría por jóvenes sin
oportunidades sin accesos sin
oportunidad laboral sin oportunidad
educativa
se enfrentan a diferentes factores de
riesgo si los podemos separar en
ambientales y personales los ambientales
pues riesgos que tienen que ver con
sociales comunitarios familiares y los
personales que incluso podría
considerarse la salud mental
y estos jóvenes imaginemos imaginemos un
caso en particular
para entenderlo pongámonos por un
segundo los zapatos de ellos e imagínate
que tú
tú tú
eres un niño de 45 años que estás en una
casa en una colonia vulnerable
que tu papá consume algún tipo de
sustancia supongamos que heroína está
constantemente consumiendo esta
sustancia que tuvo más suele trabajar
desde muy temprano te deja todo el día
con el que va y viene algún día te tomo
de la mano y a tus 56 años y te lleva
por la calle te sientes feliz porque
finalmente tu papá volteo a verte y te
lleva a pasear pero él te lleva a pasear
porque si va con un niño de la mano
cuando va a comprar su dosis es más
difícil que la patrulla lo levante y se
lo lleve a la penitenciaría es más
difícil que se lo lleve la delegación
porque es un padre con su hijo paseando
este día después de un tiempo pues
reconoce que está siendo utilizado y que
en su papá realmente lo que quiere es ir
y regresar con su dosis a casa este niño
ve a su padre consumir ve a lo mejor
algún día a su padre una sobredosis
en el baño de su casa vive
constantemente los pleitos de los papás
las discusiones
hasta que finalmente sale de casa y se
encuentra con un grupo de personas que
le encargan un día que haga un mandado
que lleve una cosa de un lado a otro
lado y lo hace bien tú sabes que si un
paquete se encarga en otro trabajo y lo
hace bien
en carga en un tercer trabajo y le dan
una remuneración ya no sólo lo están
aceptando ya no solo lo están
reconociendo además le están pagando por
hacer este trabajo hasta que un día le
encargan que comete un homicidio pero se
lo está encargando la persona que tuvo
confianza en él y que le enseñó por
primera vez lo que era pertenecer a un
grupo de personas donde se debían
lealtad entonces lo hace no sólo
cuestiona
pero finalmente entrada a la cárcel en
algunos de los homicidios tal vez en el
primero tal vez en el cuarto el joven es
aprendido
y en la cárcel necesariamente vive un
proceso un proceso que puede ser en el
caso de los casos que yo he visto
personalmente el proceso es positivo y
son jóvenes que regresan regresan a la
sociedad y regresan con unas hambres con
unam con un hambre increíble de
sobresalir de hacer las cosas bien y de
demostrar demostrarse a sí mismos que
pueden ser funcionales en la sociedad y
pueden tener una familia y pueden amar y
pueden hacer las cosas que hace
cualquiera de nosotros
yo creo que
cualquiera de nosotros que viva una
situación similar podríamos
potencialmente terminar de la misma
manera podríamos haber cometido los
mismos delitos y no nos lo hubiéramos
cuestionado ahora no lo cuestionamos y
ahora decimos cómo es posible que se
atrevan a hacer estas cosas cómo es
posible que que lleguen hasta ahí pero
yo creo que prácticamente cualquiera de
nosotros podría haberlo hecho
yo en algunos proyectos en los que he
participado con un grupo de gente muy
grande en la ciudad que también está
preocupada por estos temas y que está
preocupada por esto que ariosto
mencionaba muy bien esto que es la
segunda condena cuando no les damos una
una primera o segunda oportunidad de
estas personas para que demuestren lo
que pueden hacer por su ciudad y por
otras personas en estos proyectos que
les mencioné uno es un proyecto que le
llamamos hop rock donde los jóvenes se
capacitan un mes en el culinario art
school que es una escuela muy reconocida
de alimentos aquí de cocina aquí en
tijuana se capacita de un mes en manejo
de alimentos luego trabajan tres meses
en un futuro es sobre la parte de las
prácticas y luego se les canaliza para
para un trabajo se les queda una
actividad laboral el hayamos visto
cualquier cantidad de historias exitosas
aquí vemos algunas imágenes de los
jóvenes que han pasado por el hub track
tenemos otro proyecto también que se
llama casa de la tribu donde durante un
año se acompaña a jóvenes para que sean
emprendedores y desarrollen un negocio
pero este negocio tiene que ser una
suerte de cooperativa donde detectan una
problemática de su comunidad de su
barrio y entonces proponen un negocio
que produzca un servicio o un producto
que resuelva esa problemática y lo hacen
en un formato que es la economía social
el de economía circular donde los
jóvenes se apoyan ellos mismos pueden
vivir de eso reciben una ganancia en
dinero y pueden apoyar a otros otros
jóvenes
en resumen lo que les quiero transmitir
es estos jóvenes existen estos jóvenes
nunca han sido invisibles siempre han
estado aquí en la ciudad y siempre han
estado en nuestra sociedad y nos negamos
a verlos durante mucho tiempo yo los
invito a que los veamos ya que los
hagamos sentir que juntos podemos salir
adelante muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]